hey whatever his name broke up with me
oh oh really he said I was closed off
but like I let him in like in you know
there are other kinds of intimacy right
all the way in yeah yeah
do you approve well your dog is a 10.
I'm gonna swipe right on this one for
you all right oh my God
she's whale your league dude thank you I
know that
you must be Max hey hi this must be
Channing Tatum yeah do I look like I own
tights
this can step up I don't know it doesn't
matter well they seem to be getting
along
oh my god get away from her you boss
this is your fault I'm sorry you know
what this is my number
what are you whining about at least you
got laid I sense some sexual attention
not between you the dogs
you two are going to be grandparents
what if we as friends got them together
if just until the delivery
Kevin I guess we'll be doing it for the
kids
hey hey okay come on in anything else in
mind you'd like to take over
why are you freaking out we don't touch
it rules are how I get through the day
okay guys come on dogs hey Max what
not bad
oh my God
so wonderful to meet you Max you guys
kind of seem to balance each other out I
am literally his worst nightmare
okay I really like having you in my life
I've always just kind of been a warrior
then I met a girl who didn't really care
about my issues
[Music]
you're the two morons I got the
pregnancy test for your dog um yeah
they've been laughing at you in the back
for the last 10 minutes